when you go home for holidays for
vacation delete the word
vacation it is about to be the most
biggest emotional roller roller coaster
ride of your [__] life the amount of
verbal abuse the in 5 4 3 2 1 happy New
Year 2024 genius Brain still going
strong
dude yeah your pieces of [__] [__] how
do you how do you say it in
what happy New Year happy what Happy New
Year we were we were in San Francisco it
was a huge show like K gr it's all these
people it was like a new year show or
something downtown San Francisco it's
like thousand people and you're the
host I there and then I forgot who your
co-host was but she was like in Chinese
New Year is this David what's Happy New
Year's in
Korean Happy New
Year I remember that that was the first
time I met Kenan granis and I was like
oh my God this girl is [__] cute as
[__] I was I was kind of like who is
this she's got that AA around her like
she's so sweet yeah you know I mean I
felt like I was dirty dirtying up her
Aura like I was like spilling over to
her too much I forgot about that [__]
dude I think like half the people laugh
half the people were mortified but it's
all good oh did did you watch the new
Dave special yes what you think three
times back to back you know what's so
interesting right and I know look when
it comes to Dave Chappel obviously he
has people who love him and obviously
people who hate him like absolutely
despise him yeah they [__] wish he
dead washed yeah he's not funny like
objectively like not funny where it's
like you're crawling the delusion it's
it's funny and look you know like with
comedy obviously it's very subjective
right and then you know I get excited
whenever I watch Dave Chappelle right
Dave Chappelle was a huge part of my
childhood growing up and he molded a lot
of my [__] humor so like what he puts
out I always want to see and so right
off the bat when this special started
I'm like a this [__] starting
[__] doesn't give a [__] like last
special he said that's it no more trans
jokes from here on out yeah open this
one with a
know thinker with a good thinker
that [__] was so [__] Wheels what did
you think about it oh it was so good it
was so good right yeah I mean I can
understand why people can be offended by
it but then I feel like now you know
comedy has also gotten really really
soft for a few years and then Dave
Chappelle comes out and he kind of did
something that a lot of people wouldn't
do which was like he kind of I don't
want to this kind of sounds corny but he
kind of stood up for comedy yeah right
because everybody was getting cancelled
left and right no matter if it was a
joke or not right and I'm saying too
like there obviously there are jokes
that offend me that make me feel weird
or bad or whatever but it's in the realm
of comedy and I could choose to listen
to it and not support it or not I have
to sit there with myself too because of
like let's say for example Shane Gillis
like because of the way I grew up that
triggered the [__] out of me when I saw
that podcast cuz I'm like that guy went
to high school with me thing like that
that triggered the [__] out of me I was
like [__] that guy and then I come
across other clips and this guy's
[__] hilarious that he's [__]
hilarious like what am I supposed to do
right well that was a thing right cuz I
did a video about it and you know
obviously Joe Rogan and a lot of other
people disagree with this I just it
didn't seem like he was joking that's
why I was a little irritated I was like
oh wait he's not joking he's like like
serious this is just like a serious
topic you know what I'm saying it it
didn't sound like he was dropping a joke
he just called Andrew Yang a straight
[__] yeah I was like oh I mean I'm it's
I'm laughing now because of the
absurdity it's so absurd but when you
watch it it's like is is this this is
not a joke yeah and so when I did that
video I was I was the the thing that I
was saying was like there was no joke it
was just it was it was actually him just
being very genuine it sounded like he
was being very genuine you so I I didn't
find it [__] funny at all because I
there was no joke in it and so that's
why I didn't like it and then lo and
behold he comes out of nowhere with this
special on YouTube and he drops it and
it was one of my favorite specials that
I've seen in a long [__] hilarious
time like it's kind of sad like I I wish
that people listen like cuz who did he
say to Andrew yang right M and then
Andrew Yang straight up forgave himh
quit the quickness MH and then he Andrew
Yang brought him on his own podcast they
talked oneon-one for an hour you know
Andrew Yang even though he's um a
secular or non-religious his one of his
core principles in his campaign is
forgiveness oh really isn't that wild he
yeah he's like look everybody makes
mistakes and you we have to show that
people can be better yeah so that was
part of his campaign that's why he
stepped up for chain Gillis oh but what
happened anyway SNL fired him lost all
that so I was curious I looked up his
old other skits right they're [__]
hilarious [__] hilarious are so the
only fan dad is so [__] dumb dude
it's hilarious cuz he has one where he's
like a canceled firefighter oh yeah he
like saves out a burning building the
news is like but you said this thing
like 5 years ago and then it's like it I
I get it where it's like okay this [__]
really Burns but then um there's a
important thing that Dave Chappelle says
everything's funny until it happens to
you yeah right and so but the the fact
is everybody gets it yeah that's why
when he started going in on the handicap
J he was proving a point yeah the
handicap trans gay Asian black white
dude everybody's going to get it and
that's I think that's what I genuinely
liked about his like standup right and
there was like certain stuff too where
he's he was very good and I'm not like
hyper analyzing this stuff I'm just
talking about what made me laugh right
there was a couple of jokes that I
thought was kind of distasteful until
like he brought like he you know he did
that you know kind of like that corny
Asian that one that that's a little
weird I was like that's kind of like I
can see why people saying like he's
going through low hanging fruit and then
he wrapped it back to his wife she
pulled pushed her nose down and pushed
her lips I was like oh he got us gave it
right back to himself too right I mean
those were the things I I was asking
myself cuz there sometimes you laugh
you're like oh [__] am I supposed to
laugh yeah yeah yeah and I think that's
one of the great things about comedy
it's is that part of is about introspect
about yourself like why are you laughing
at it when it's something that is
painful right there's this relatability
but we also have to understand how
laughter does like work in its own
therapeutic sense yeah right but if
you're going to sit there and not laugh
at anything and be straight-faced yeah
just to prove a point you paid a ticket
you went to a show just to give him a
sour look yeah and not laugh I always
found that weird too right like people
go to I I don't know if it's like this
performance activism that we have now
right like it's so performative like you
had to buy like you know Dave Chappelle
talked about that that moment where the
person who attacked him is like dog you
bought like front row tickets like what
do you mean like this is this is [__]
nuts I guarantees those tickets are
anywhere between 5 to 10 G's Hollywood
Bowl yeah yeah expensive as [__] and
he's like you he was like you're the
richest poor person ever been in my life
the front [__] row yeah so you know
like this like performance activism too
where people go to these comedy shows to
hear somebody do comedy and be offended
and then cause a scene knowing that
there's cameras there and for what like
what are you trying to prove here like
the great thing about like ENT
entainment actually you know what just
in general art right yeah you could like
it or dislike it it is completely up to
you right and I think that's what it's
supposed to be it you know Patrice
O'Neal said it best he goes half the
crowd should be dying laughing and the
other half should be mortified because
you're supposed to be saying something
right and I and I think that a lot of
the times not a lot of the times I I
would say it's kind of going back to
where comedy was where it's a little
normal and obviously there were things
that were problematic back in the past
that kind of fixed itself along the way
because time changes right Eddie Murphy
talked about how he'll go back to his
CPS and he cringes every time he says
you know the word [__] right and he
goes but he can't change that yeah the
only thing he could do now is not say
that word now in an offensive way right
and that's the thing too like
forgiveness like things happen and
change over time and sometimes people
crucify you for what you do in the past
and they think it's your present yeah
you know what I'm saying and I think
it's like people show change and and
what whatnot I would like that Grace too
because there's going to be a moment in
your life where you [__] up so [__]
hard and you're going to wish that
someone would show you just a little bit
of Grace because they get to see the
person that you are now right cuz I I am
not the same person I was 10 years ago
right arguably for me I'm
worse no I'm not going
to no you are a better person David give
yourself some credit don't be hard on
yourself I think now I just I just care
a lot less but I will say this though
like as I've grown older I became a lot
more empathetic there there aren't as
many hard lines for me you know what I'm
saying every year I gain a little bit
more I get a little more introspective
and I also become a lot more forgiving
because I've experienced a lot more and
then I become a lot more understanding
when I was younger I just didn't [__]
care whether this person who pissed me
off died lived or survived or whatever
it doesn't [__] matter especially if
someone's trying to get you mad on
purpose yeah and then you get mad they
win but when we were younger we're like
[__] that you don't give a [__] and
you're just going to show out and then
now that I'm older and I find someone
who's deliberate ly trying to piss me
off like I can use my words yeah I can
use my attitude and I can use just my
own patience and maturity like to walk
through it like there are there are
times where I'll be shaking I'll even
get cramps cuz I'm like like yeah
holding up my body right and I got to
take my time like anything I do in Anger
is anything good GNA happen I going to
make a good decision yeah how many times
after you make a choice out of anger
have you regretted it yeah it's a
majority of the time 99% it's a majority
of the time yeah and those those kind of
things too like I I think I really enjoy
about getting older you know since we're
talking about like the new year is you
know there's always a page that you the
page always turns no matter what right
you can't really stop that and
whatever's written in the past is
written but you can only but when you
write that new chapter you can make sure
that it's just better than what you
wrote before and that's why like Mariel
was asking me too she goes I I'm
actually surprised what she said to me
was that you get excited for the new New
Year because you don't care about
birthdays weddings celebrations all
these days kind of seem the same to you
she goes why does the New Year always
feel good for you it's like well I don't
know it's just the idea that I get to
start fresh yes right and I I know
people are going to say you never get to
start fresh I understand that but I like
the I like the I like to entertain the
thought that I could yeah right I mean
it's an attitude it's a perspective
thing right like if you say that look
you can be a nihilist like I have like I
am sometimes many times and just say
it's arbitrary we just around the Sun
and it's going to keep [__] spinning
for all eternity you know and just
because we figured out when the exact
spot is or whatever you can say it like
that right it doesn't matter life goes
on or you can be like I gained weight
this year yeah uh I haven't cut my hair
yeah um and you can look at yourself and
be like assess yourself for a sec how
was your year yeah I think every the
fact that humans have that ability to be
like okay review let's let's talk about
this deep brief this year what I did
wrong what I did right what I liked what
I didn't like you know humans do that if
we were still monkeys if we were still
AES yo World Keeps spinning let me throw
my [__] yeah you know yeah I mean I yeah
like so like for 2024 too for me
specifically like you know and I've
talked about this years ago like on my
on my when I used to do like these
personal Vlogs and videos one of the
things that I always do like towards the
end of the years like I figure out these
I I always figure out I know it sounds a
little cynical but I figure everything
that I [__] up on yeah right and I
like doing that because then I could
just figure out what I'm not going to do
next year yes you know what I'm saying
and I know a lot of people when they do
their uh their their stupid ass
mindfulness journals okay it's not
stupid I'm sorry I apologize if you guys
do that and that helps you out it's
stupid hey man I'm K it's stupid my my
therapist is forcing me to do that [__]
every day a lot of people enjoy that
because it helps them to be grateful I
don't like it that's not the My Method
my methodology I don't know if it's
because of the way that I grew up is
what did I [__] up on I don't like that
[__] and I'm going to change it and that
makes me feel good because it shows that
I have ability an ability to change and
grow right so like one of the things
that I wrote is like kind of getting
tasks done when I need to get done so I
have a habit of like looking somebody
has to get done today and I just
go and then I'll go t to the Garden
right so yesterday we I if you said and
then I want to play Spider-Man 2 if
you're like yeah I know you
sh but then it's like
[Laughter]
yeah so now and it's funny too now that
I'm you know this year I've already
started this and I'm doing things my
whole day is pack I'm like [__] I have
there's so much [__] to do it's like
stuff that I've ignored yeah you know
and I and I just don't want to be that
person who's like hyper avoidant so
that's the stuff that I'm going to work
on this year uh for me personally cuz I
I feel like I need to just kind of get
things done and do it in a timely manner
because things tend to pile up for me
and then I get stressed the [__] out and
I I just don't want to do that [__]
anymore yeah my what was your resolution
last year it was to lose weight and then
I gained 15 PBS but you did lose you
gained that 15 PBS with the holidays
give yourself some credit bro give it
give yourself some credit yeah I mean
this year too like you know we always
talk about health right and look this is
actually a very good subject to get into
like um this this year
alone uh in the last month three people
that I know their parents almost died
from health issues right and this is
like the most annoying thing and I'm not
sure if you guys deal with this tooo if
you're an immigrant or you have Asian
parents Asian parents are literally the
stupidest thing people I've ever met in
my life they don't [__] they don't
know [__] they don't know [__] but they
always talk like they know [__] [__]
yeah it's like why' you make me do the
taxes when I was in high school huh yeah
why'd you make me pick up all the
government phone calls huh let me tell
you something and I wanted to talk about
this and I saved it for this podcast
because I feel like you could
relate when you go home for holidays for
vacation delete the word vacation
it is about to be the most biggest
emotional roller roller coaster ride of
your [__] life the amount of verbal
abuse the amount of [__] thrown at
you I'm a grown ass man do you even love
me let me tell you him your son Ed let
me tell you this [__] right so I go into
the house and I I sleep in this room
like it's my room growing up and it's
smelling a little funky and I don't know
why so lo and behold I find out that
they had a flood and the carpet got wet
right and my dad didn't change the
carpet you have to there's no way he was
standing to his garden yeah so you know
and so this day this is this is such a
weird story I'm in the room and I'm in
there with Mariel right and we're doing
our thing sleeping and not not [__]
we're sleeping right and then we just go
it kind of smells funny in here and I
noticed like this yellow spot on the
floor o and so my parents have a lot of
dogs and so I go out to Walmart I get
the dog pee cleaner because if you guys
don't have any animals you can't just
get rid of dog urine cat urine with just
regular cleaning products you need a
certain spray that breaks down the
enzyme that's in urine that gets rid of
the smell so I start spraying it down
and then my dad comes in and he goes
what are you doing and I'm like well the
dog peed in the room he goes no they
didn't and I'm like what I'm looking at
him and I look at Mariel I look at my
dad I'm like it's yellow
did you I was like it's yellow he goes I
cleaned the carpet because the the house
flooded so that's not dog pee and I'm
like when did you when did this happen
he goes 3 months ago and I'm like so
within this 3 months you're telling me
that there's not a chance that a dog
could have peed in this room he goes no
it's not pee and I'm like Dad I know
what pee smells like this is [__] pee
what is he embarrassed why is he denying
this is what I'm saying and so my mom
comes and she goes what's the problem
why are you guys yelling I'm like he's
telling me that this huge yellow spot on
the carp is not PE and we could all
smell that it's [__] pee right he
goes listen listen listen stop talking
he's like yelling now he goes stop
talking you need to listen 3 months ago
the room flooded and I'm like oh okay
Noah all right I don't want to hear
about this FL he goes okay the I was
like I know it did you just told me that
he goes I got a carp he starts going to
this long diet tribe about how he clean
the carpet thoroughly whatever whatnot
and I'm like what the [__] does that
have to do with the dog pee right here
this is the dumbest conversation I've
ever because you're not giving him the
credit for doing all the cleaning before
I really and so my mom stops and she
looks at both of us she looks at my dad
she goes literally in Korean you know
are you [__] my dad she's like what
is your problem he goes even if it's not
dog pee just let him clean it yeah who
cares what is your problem and you know
he does the he does this thing that
pisses me off it's very condescendent he
goes he laughs in my face he goes H
whatever and he just walks out and my
blood is [__] boiling like what what
was all that about what was it for I
don't [__] and my mom's looking at me
she's like is that dog pee I was like
yeah you smell it too right she goes
yeah it's clearly dog pea and then she
goes out and my mom's trying to talk to
my dad he goes don't talk to me anymore
you're pissing me off don't talk to me
for the rest of the night and so I'm
irritated now right I go out my laptop's
on the table and just my my life is a
[__] sitcom I go out I grab my laptop
I put it in the room and then all of a
sudden Riley my dog start sniffing my
laptop all over the place I'm like what
are you sniffing at why are you sniffing
at my laptop I look at my laptop I smell
it one of the dogs pissed on my laptop
oh my God my
$5,000 [__] MacBook Pro MacBook Pro
pissed on my first of all it was on the
dining table that means one of the dogs
somehow like an Olympic Athlete jumped
onto the dining table lifted his stank
ass [__] leg and pissed on my [__]
laptop is your desktop background a
[__] fire
HR like what the [__] and so in my room
I just go what the [__] and then my mom
she goes what I was like one of your
stupid [__] dogs pissed on my laptop
and then my dad just goes into his room
and closes the door cuz now he has to
admit that this dog is pissing
everywhere yeah he can't admit that he
was wrong DG I don't know why but that
that is the downfall Korean men I swear
to God what the [__] is the deal with
being absolutely yeah wrong objectively
wrong about something but believing
they're right yeah like I I remember we
were at a chaman je and um a Chinese
Korean Chinese restaurant
and the the paper uh plate holders
whatever they have like sat questions
multiple choice and so we're doing this
and that and who knows what the question
is it was a math question one of the
dudes got it clearly wrong and all of us
got it right so we're like kind of like
oh dude blah blah blah I think cuz he
was feeling you know like dumb yeah he
was like no way and he was straight up
trying to show the work and everything
to try to prove all of us are wrong so
hey let me just double down on that
right so my dad gets embarrassed he
comes out of the room he still wants to
explain why he's right oh God right none
of us blood relatives want to hear his
[__] so guess who he grabs my
wife I'm in this room just thank God I
had a cover and shield all over my
laptop so it's fine right I just had to
peel off everything take it off and then
throw that stuff away and the laptop was
perfect thank God I did that and so I
just hear my dad talking out of his
[__] Korean ass about [__] and my
dad grabs my wife and sits her down he
goes let me explain to you what happened
cuz none of us want to hear this
[__] she like she was in the room
when right he goes the smell that you're
not that you're smelling right now is
not actually because the the carpet is
is dirty it is cu it's moldy right cuz
we all know what a dirty rag smells like
yeah and he goes it's not because of
that he goes I use a machine an ozone
machine and so the ozone machine you
know basically takes the bacteria flips
it out and so it makes it smell like
fish and I'm like where are you getting
this information you [__] psychopath
and I he Mar see Mar just nodding her
head nodding her head and she goes oh
I'm learning something new and I looked
and I grabbed her I was like stop he's
lying to you he's making up [__]
right now this guy is a dumbass and so I
come out the room right and my dad is
still going on and on about this and I'm
like hey hey nobody cares be quiet cuz
I'm so pissed right I was like stop
telling her your boring stories and she
he's like it's not boring it's right and
I'm like oh God oh my God and then my
mom comes out again right cuz she now
cuz he escaped to the room before and
she's like what is your problem he goes
don't talk to me and he gets up and he
just closes goes back to his room and
closes the door I'm like this is here's
the thing too now my mom's mad at me
right you did this so let me tell you
what my mom does my mom looks at me
right and she goes hey I know like the
dog peed on all your stuff or whatever
but there's no reason for you to be
mad dud [__] I looked at her
right and I go hey you have the worst
temper I've ever seen in my life who the
[__] are you you talking to literally
this morning my dad went to the grocery
store he got a bottle of soy sauce and
you screamed at him because it was the
wrong size WR size yeah she went are you
dumb how many times have I we gotten the
same soy sauce why would you get this
size you're the dumbest I was like you
got mad over soy sauce me your stupid
dog literally could have ruined all my
life's work like that am I not allowed
to be mad I'm like when when somebody is
wrong and they're mad I'm allowed to be
mad let me be mad don't tell me not to
be mad right then she doubles down and
this is a great example of how Asian
parents never want to be wrong this is
how much my mom wanted to be right she
looks me dead in the face right and mind
you I just told you that the dog peed on
the carpet she goes well this is your
fault I'm like how is this my fault she
goes you're the one who asked for carpet
when we read this house in that room and
you know what I was de
Ed I was 10 years old you're the one who
wanted carpet so that's why this
happened I was
10 I was 10 years old oh God I'm so
sorry this woman went all the way back
in time Back to the Future style and
said this is the impetus when you were
10 you asked for carpet in this room she
said that like Dead face stonefly effect
butterfly effect and that's why the dog
PE I at that moment I'm like dude
somebody just killed me what [__]
world do I live in I looked at her dead
in the windows of her soul and I said
are you are you serious I was dead she
go and then she looks at me she goes I
don't [__] care I'm so sick of it and
I'm like sick of what dude oh my gosh
dude so I go back into the room and I'm
venting to Mariel right and I stop and I
go I bet you my mom's still pissed so I
go back outside and this is this is just
to give you a glimpse of who my mother
is I go back outside she's in the
hallway she's walking I stop I look at
her we look at each other I open up my
arms for a hug she steps back and she
goes go kill
yourself
dog
dog too soon cuz I
mean oh my God it's in the news like
come on Mom she goes go kill yourself
and I just look at her and I start
laughing and I just and I go back and
then she looks at me and then she's
explaining herself right she goes you
know how would you feel if you had a
child and they told you that they
couldn't sleep because of dogs were
barking they were peeing all over the
stuff and it makes them hard for them to
come back home I would be like I would
fix my house fix your [__] yeah what are
you talking about and then Mariel comes
out and she sees us kind of arguing and
then our argument starts turning into
laugh there and then we start cracking
up because it's just such a stupid
conversation that we start to realize
this is the dumbest this only happens in
our family this is the weirdest [__]
situation my dad is still in the room
right cuz he doesn't want to come out
cuz he's so [__] embarrassed yeah and
I think what I realized at that point
was he I think he was embarrassed
because this happened while Mariel was
here right his daughter-in-law who he
loves a lot and he's like a little
embarrassed and a little ashamed cuz he
did all this effort to vacuum and get
all the water out but it doesn't matter
you have to rip the carpet out it's
there's no there's no other solution for
it and so then I looked at him as a
human being I was like oh he's a little
embarrassed or whatever and of course
the next day he acts like nothing ever
happened right right oh do you want
breakfast what's going on I'm like you
[__] you just caused this whole
ordeal yesterday you like literally it
could have just been me spraying the
carpet and getting rid of the smell and
then it went into this huge thing where
my mom told me to go kill myself like I
know how it started from a dog piss to
go kill yourself but somewhere in
between it all connected right here god
dude thank God cuz I I called my mom I
said I'm coming home for Christmas and
New Year's and she goes where why um to
see you my mom she's like what are you
going to do you're just going to sit at
home do nothing right you want to come
to the store and I was like well I don't
want to go to the gas station yep so I
was okay I'll stay I'll stay in La so I
didn't do [__] all week yeah like damn
so I'm glad I didn't have any of that
[__] I mean look your mom is so
funny too cuz like you know when when we
talk about the stories of like your
father and then goes to your mom it's
like I don't know your mom kind of
sounds a lot like your dad yeah I don't
know you kind of sound like the SJ name
in this picture like or the Hony right
yeah like there there are a few things
where I look at like when I when I talk
about stories about my dad's crazy
[__] and I'm like you know what I
think my mom was a real gangster you
know my mom putting up with this [__]
yeah like uh there is a time where my
dad would just be missing and [__] right
and so um he was driving this uh black
BMW um and so my mom would take me and
my brother and we're Toddlers and she'd
drive around K Town looking for his car
and so she'll find like a billiard's
place like a Tang Jang take us up there
just shove Us in the door and bounce cuz
he has to take you back home yeah and
then she are like hey whose kids are
these and then my dad would see us and
then he'd take us home that's so
traumatizing dude that's so [__]
traumatizing that's a crazy [__] like
like my household too was just
like it's either like you feel like like
do you love me or do you not give a [__]
but it was kind of like also like do you
think I'm dumb
yeah it's it's it's such a weird thing
like to go back onto the topic of like
how Asian parents are the most
ridiculous creatures on Earth they just
not only can they not admit that they're
wrong it is the hardest thing to get
them to be healthy right because they
know everything like science can improve
or whatever and they can want us to be a
doctor but if we tell them to go see a
doctor they're like what do they know
like why the [__] would you want us to
be a physician if you even you don't
even trust them my dad is the purest
example of that like when you saw him I
like he was 53 you saw him he looked
like he was 80 yeah right because when
he was 40
like he looked like like me yeah and
then he went to a doctor to get a
checkup and he went to obviously a
Korean doctor apparently that Korean
doctor just cussed him out just was like
the [__] is wrong with you you're almost
40 and you're smoking and you you have
heart disease and all of this and you
have blessure heart disease in his 40s
something like that yeah yeah he smoked
a lot man and so the doctor like chewed
his ass out and you know what my dad did
I like [__] it I guess I'm dying oh so
he went hard for the last last years it
was hard to live with him cuz he didn't
give a [__] oh [__] he went straight
selfish mode and like just spent all the
money put us in so much debt and like
bought [__] and random things like I
would I remember finding like a mini
motorbike in the garage like the [__]
are you doing with that I like how the
doctor well first of all the doctor is a
jackass that's not don't go to a Korean
doctor guys yeah it's like they're like
I'm dying from cancer CH like go die
what's wrong with you what' you do it's
your fault that's the worst thing I've
ever heard in my life and also I find it
hilarious that your dad when the doctor
said you can die if you continue this
life all he heard was I'm dying soon
yeah that's what he heard I'm dying soon
and then he just survived for the next
20 years [__] up all your lives just
just going crazy selling drugs doing
drugs like going went to prison like
just still just not giving a [__] that's
[__] insane man I I I could only
imagine what that like cuz like you know
my dad it it hardened us for sure I mean
for you have to either that or you just
go [__] crazy or become the
middleweight champion of the world yeah
you know but my um my cousin was in
Washington at the same time too and then
I remember my mom just being beaw at her
she was like she's so Saga Jobo which is
like disrespectful right she was like
looking back like I remember going to
their house and then they go all crazy
and their parents didn't yell at them
and then one time I saw my uncle put his
hand over her arm and slap his own arm
and she's like stop it right and she
goes I went that y like why'd you hit me
and then I'm like what kind of soft ass
household why is my that's my mom's
brother so when we come home and like my
mom's mean as
[__] and my dad don't give a [__] and so
I'm like wh what what is this differ and
then I realized yeah like in our
household like different from all my
cousins and all that because of my dad
was then I look back like what you said
about trying to understand your dad yeah
and looking back at my dad making all
these [__] up decisions I mean I it
clearly stems from his abandonment
issues from being adopted then knowing
that he has a whole ass family in Korea
like a big one and he couldn't go
because he been to prison that means he
can't come back to America poor his ass
I mean it's yeah I mean our parents they
definitely went through a lot right and
I think that that wisdom only comes with
getting older right but when you're in
it it's so hard to see any of this
[__] stuff cuz you're just dealing
with this [__] all the [__] time
do you wonder what your hu was like to
your dad too just acting the same way
well so with my dad I found out that so
I the only things I know about my Dad is
through my mom because my dad doesn't
really talk to us like people
right he treats you like his little
peon he can only give us commands and my
dad is actually very sweet if you if
anybody meets my dad he's like the
sweetest guy ever right cuz he's very
kind but when he talks to us he doesn't
know how to speak to us and it gets to
the point where I think my dad is trying
to learn how to be like kind and do nice
things but it's foreign to him right
it's very foreign so now he's it's like
watching an alien trying to understand
human beings right like when Terminator
tries to smile so I think when he was
younger when we were younger he didn't
know how to be kind and loving so now
he's trying now but he's just developed
into this really annoying
person so it's too much yeah right I
mean yeah I have to you know my my my
dad had this crazy transformation like
the last two years of his life like he
went to this uh other Church in Tacoma
some dude like prayed for him and I
don't know D balling felt like a healing
in his life and he tried to turn that
around right he went to this thing
called abui hako father School get the
[__] out of here yeah it's a thing send
your dad they had the thing
in right and they talk to Korean dads
like look man like here's our culture
and what we've been taught and then they
try to break it down so it's weird like
I know what you mean when my dad started
trying to be nice yeah I get a phone
call he's like hey
Edward uh hia you good
[Music]
yeah I love you I love you okay I love
you too Dad and then he goes into the
bathroom and throws up yeah I could tell
it was the most awkward thing I think it
was like one of those tasks they made
him do at the school to call your kids
and say you love them my dad is so bad
at Being Human now to the point where
when we were younger like Mariel hates
this phrase right which is like whenever
she goes through something and I said
this to her and I caught myself s
because I started I'm like oh this is my
[__] my parents would say me so Mariel
would like let's say she hurts her wrist
right and she goes oh it hurts and I
would say this I'd be
like which means like you're not going
to die shut up and you just move on but
this you know it's not very kind but
that's what I was taught when I was a
kid and so but sometimes too when you
know people go through these uh I would
say huge life-changing moments right and
they want to better themselves they also
forget too it's like the the the burning
force that you left behind you it's
still there right and they immediately
want forgiveness now it's like that
doesn't work right you can continue to
grow as an individual and fix your [__]
well now it's up to me or when I get to
decide to forgive you yeah right cuz it
can't be just immediate it maybe it is
for certain people but that's up to us
to decide right and so my dad when he
started like softening up and being
really kind and I really appreciate it
but I'm not used to this [__] freak
of nature coming at me asking I'm okay
right so it got to the point now where
my I think my dad's like oh I should ask
my kids questions right but it's the
most annoying [__] questions on Earth
is they're like useless questions usess
can I just say this and this is real
[__] I'm not lying uh what time is it
I'm I'm I'm no I'm sitting right and I'm
eating food and he'll say [__] like this
he goes you like to chew your
food so you like chewing huh
yeah and I'm not even [__] lying
and I'm looking at it like are you
[__] like what are you talking about
right now I'm sorry are you award yeah
and then he goes I'm like yeah I'm
chewing my food he
goes he just thereare at I'm okay and
then I'm just eating and then my stomach
kind of grow grumbles he goes you have
diarrhea he he's concerned I said are
you trying to show that you're worried
about me right now he goes you have
diarrhea you need medicine are you
constipated what's wrong with your
stomach are you sick do you have the flu
and I look at my mom and my mom just in
a distance she just hear go shut
up like what's wrong with you leave him
alone let him eat he goes who I'm just
I'm just talking to him and I'm like
okay I get it you're trying to talk to
me ask me how my day was why are you
asking me if I have loose stool like
this is not normal man so uh you blink
your eyes
yeah so by the way you know I
I'm
like for some reason I thought it was
going to be a good idea to be in
Sacramento for seven to eight days and I
[__] up yeah I was like oh I'm here
too long this is this is crazy it's like
Max three days days huh and then my
mom's like you look like you haven't
gotten any sleep I'm like no [__] yeah
what did I walk into let me just chill
you know you're kind of cry like right
now let me just eat you know and then
obviously there's so many other things
that you could get into like I can't
even process what I went through I feel
like I was there looken if I'm going to
hell this is where this you go to it's
your
no I start repenting immediately you
walk in it just smells like
mold and it's I just go Deja Vu every
day of my dad going listen is not the
dog
appear it's ozone it's a smell of ozone
smell like a
[Applause]
pish I would literally [__] lose my
mind dude I can't do that again but I
can see where it's like you have to
acknowledge that he's trying to love you
right yes it's because you didn't
acknowledge the fact that he cleaned the
carpet that he was so mad yeah that he
put all this effort into yeah and then
all he could see was like this carpet oh
I cleaned it and I'm literally telling
him just let me clean this dog
pee like to the point where he goes it's
he's so adamant that it's not yeah so
like do you find it tough when he asks
you [__] like you're like chewing and
you have to like patronize that like yes
like so he he also receives that like
acknowledgement of love you know here's
here's my problem I don't know how to
respond to that without giving him
attitude because it's just so weird
right and I'm also used to my dad
talking to me like I'm the dumbest
person on earth so no matter what he
says the my first reaction is to get get
defensive right and i' I've gotten a lot
better at it and that's actually my bad
and sometimes when he says regular stuff
like I'll get defensive immediately and
then I have to apologize to I'm like oh
I'm sorry like I I thought you meant
this and it's not that and my dad's like
oh I was like I don't know why you're
being so mean and I'm like you want to
go back the last 20 years just accept
apology and then move on dude right and
that's like stuff that I have to learn
that's all PTSD stuff right so when your
dad or your parents the first thing that
comes out their mouth is like why are
you so stupid it's like you're kind of
used to going like oh I have to defend
myself everything that I do in the house
every move that I [__] make I feel
like I'm making a mistake yeah I mean it
there's a it's a weird thing where I
don't know if it's Koreans and the
family and honor kind of system whatever
it is but then it's like you hear from
your wife friends and are like just no
contact stop talking to your mom yeah
don't go to your mom's house and you're
like what don't talk to your mom what
and then these Concepts have to like go
through your head for a sec so so like
years ago uh I'm G to say it was like
eight years now uh I had to leave LA and
go back to Washington and I'm already
feeling shitty about that I didn't want
to do the
move and so I'm like super depressed I
told you this
and I'm like you know I have like nobody
talked about my mom cuz I'm at her place
and I'm like yeah I'm I'm depressed you
know like like I talk about like like Su
suicide like chush right but I didn't
say the word suicide it's like chush you
know like like or something cuz I
couldn't get the right word my Korean
sucks and then in it just twist of fate
she gets a phone call in the middle of
that and then she goes oh wait she picks
up the phone call instead it's my cousin
and I could hear it's like and she's
like oh yeah yeah he's good oh yeah he
say he depressed she's like laugh about
it he he wants to kill
himself and I'm like what the [__] yeah
Edward's a gay yeah like he likes his
coach I'm like what the [__] I mean I'm
kind of laughing on the inside cuz it's
like it's the most ridiculous thing but
it's like I need you yeah she doesn't
get it she doesn't [__] care so years
later like here I am like we get we on a
huge
fight and that kind of [__] is in the
back of my head always like it it was on
my [__] list of course you know of all
the things like and I I didn't speak up
or nothing and so all of it comes out
and then the most hurtful thing I've
told my mom was like you don't know how
to love you don't know what love is
simple you don't know understand any of
the Lang you have no love
language actually yeah you know I was
like think about it on my like it was
harsh it was harsh but you know I left
and we didn't talk for a long time and
through therapy and such right it was
like learning about my mom and the way
she loves is she gives money right oh
that's so Korean yeah yeah and for me
I'm like that feels like you're buying
your forgiveness yeah yeah you're buying
like the the relationship you know
Redemption one has that ever worked out
you it never works out that way and so I
I started getting even more like
resentful of the fact so I was just like
don't give me money show me love I
challenge you right and she was and she
said it straight up I don't know that
this is my love yeah and I was like then
I don't want and I was like so mad it's
like not about money and that's where I
left and over time I realized my my
therapist goes are you crazy it's free
money take the money yeah it's like she
feels loved when you take her money yeah
and you but you are rejecting it because
of that and it's like she was like if
that is what you say and that is all she
knows she's giving it to you yeah she
was like receive her love I know it's
money it's like that's a cherry on top
but it's like if you reciprocate by
receiving that money your mom will feel
loved so I was like [__] all right and
then I started taking it whenever she
offered her relationship has gotten
better and better she's so much nicer
like all right just give me money yeah
yeah yeah so was the reciprocation if
that was her sign of of love that and
and she felt assured that I wasn't angry
I had her I didn't hate her and I was I
wasn't saying some [__] like you don't
know how to love yeah you know and
saying she was a bad mother she's like
ah it's not enough
money I got you yeah but over time yeah
it was like okay we made a habit of just
constantly just telling each other we do
love each other you know CU we have like
such a tough relationship cuz like the
hard part I know for a lot of people
when you they're like in your
predicament it's it's not so much that
that it's like oh this is the way that
they give love and I should accept that
cuz it makes them feel loved is that
sometimes when a person feels wronged
they don't want to take that version of
love because I don't want you to feel
that this is a pass yeah right it's like
you take that money they go and then she
feels good it's like you don't deserve
to feel good that's the hard part cuz
here's something that really [__] me
up and actually I I had a spiral moment
cuz um I had to take her to the airport
right
but the thing was like I was supposed to
get 5 days of training right to watch
the gas station so she can go to Korea
and then I was going to watch the store
for a month
right I land in Washington she's like
okay I'm going to Korea tomorrow I'm
like you're not going to train me yeah
and I started telling like are you crazy
I was like this is your business yeah
and you're just going to leave it to me
and you're not going to think about it
and and I was like why did you even make
this decision yeah right and she's like
oh this pastor told me that you'll be
fine who the [__] is this
pastor and she was like this lady and
I'm like does she even know who I am
have I met have I ever talked to her
yeah yeah yeah I'm like do you not see
oh my this is [__] crazy it's m right
and then I was like so upset she was
like okay okay what do you want then
right I was like oh my are you going to
say you were wrong say sorry she said
why I paid you oh my God she said I'm
paying you
that's what I'm talking about right
there they think it's like an unlimited
P right it's like that's the hard part
too is cuz and maybe that's a sign of
either maturity or us kind of learning
how to draw certain boundaries where you
know for me if I was in your situation
it would be very very hard for me to
take that money because in the most
vindictive way possible I know that if I
take that money she feels better and
then how come I I have to feel like [__]
and you get to feel good always like
this that was me for a long time yeah
was being like I reject your money cuz I
know it'll make her feel bad yeah and
that's like the hard part right like and
I think that takes over time maturity is
like okay what what's the end result
that we want here if we want our
relationship to be better then I if I if
I take this money and then I could work
towards something better then maybe
that's what I have to accept it's just
really hard when the [__] that
you're trying to make feel better is the
one that you kind of just [__] hate
you know it's this person that always
makes me feel less than yeah but the one
that I told I was going to kill myself
and then she started doing a [__]
roast with other relatives on the phone
as I'm sitting right here like I'm right
here
dude could would you have like got into
another room and closed the door like
I'm right here and then she's like
pointing at you
like I get it mom [__] [__] Jesus
Christ new resolution is to yeah
understand more you know empathize more
love my mom Beyond just you know re I
call just the call see what's up you
know and like that that is me like
growing up mending some [__] you know
because even my siblings are like are
you are you going to over that [__]
yeah I mean it's hard right like you
when some people too when they ask like
when are you going to get over and I'm
I'm like like like that too like I get
it right but you know I feel like you're
you and your siblings experiences with
your parents are also vastly [__]
different very very very different like
my experience like my brother's
experience and my experience with my dad
are two different things right so how he
feels about my dad and how I feel about
my dad are very very different like my D
my brother gets annoyed of my dad I go
through the thought of
like sometimes not not now but before it
was like I [__] hate you you me damn
like body slam you yeah it's like I
[__] hate I'm bigger now yeah like it
went to that type of thought right and
like that's also based on my immaturity
and kind of also based on the stuff that
he did like listen I still don't have it
as bad as some other people definitely
not you Jesus
Christ you know what I mean like you're
your [__] on another Stratosphere my
father was around he worked his ass off
um he was caring and kind and loving to
the to the best of his ability my dad is
just a socially awkward guy and he's
emotionally stunted and he doesn't know
how to do it like I said he's asking me
if I had diarrhea you know and I just
take it as you're trying but it's still
annoying but if you didn't maintain the
relationship would you see any growth in
you how who would you be today if you
just no contact your dad 10 years ago
cuz of some [__] oh for sure like
sticking sticking through it also helped
me to realize like my faults right
yeah everybody kind of wants this like
relationship with somebody where
everything is perfect but my best
relationships have never been perfect
yeah right we kind of like had these
moments in the pockets where we come in
and out we disagree but then we always
came became strong from it and that's
even my relationship with Mariel yeah
right we got we have you know I've
talked on the podcast where before we uh
got engaged I basically left her I was
like oh I'm done with you I can't I
don't love you I literally told her
interface I don't love you if you left
tomorrow I'd be a lot happier right and
then from that now we're like the
happiest we've ever been got married and
we got married and it took time for that
stuff now that I look at it it go you
know when people tell me sometimes they
go oh what would you do after you if you
and Mariel happened to split I was like
I really wouldn't know
because I a lot of the great qualities
that I have now is because of everything
that we went through right if Mariel and
I split the next person that I'm with
you you are now a benefactor of all the
stuff that has changed in me because of
the relationship I had with her yeah
right and you probably wouldn't have
been able to experience that if I wasn't
with somebody like her yeah right and so
that's the that's the thing too like if
I think about if she leaves me I'm like
damn dude like I don't know if I could
go go through this whole thing again you
know like getting married again get
married again going through all the
struggles the fights to get to know each
other I don't think I have the patience
for that anymore hey we we got a buddy
you know who who's going through it and
that's what he says too he's like I
don't think I'll ever get married again
it's not worth it it's just so hard
right and I can't and people have even
asked like what happens if Mariel died
like I was like listen if she died I
would even find it and I know this
sounds like like I'm over Ro like over
romanticizing things I think I would be
very it would be very hard for me to get
with somebody else I might just be
single for the rest of my life yeah only
because we there was
no we didn't get to close this chapter
right it was she was just taken from me
so now it's just she's still the love of
my life she's right there how can I be
with somebody else maybe just for maybe
just a [__] right yeah but that's really
about it but to get married to somebody
to be dedicated and say that I love you
more than anything in this world I don't
think so I think it would be that person
that's that's dead you know that and I
would feel feel very dishonest yeah you
know I mean like [__] people feel that
way about their dogs yeah you know what
I mean rep their dogs yeah they just
won't get another dog they'll try
they'll get a donkey before they get a
dog 100% like even now when like with my
very first dog I still love that dog so
so much and you know when I was a kid
too I didn't know how to take care of
dogs and my dad took care of dogs like
an old Korean man does like picking it
up by his ears and slapping slapping it
around chaining it up you know what I
mean it it didn't get to stay inside the
house it was in the backyard in its
little Korean Boomers cannot take care
of dogs yeah anyway you know in that dog
house and I think about that dog even
now about like how sad his existence was
cuz he just wanted to be close to us and
he never got to and he would scratch at
the back door to hang out and I would
play with him as much as I could but
then my dad wouldn't let him in the
house and it just like what the [__] man
so like that I actually still think
about that till this day it's like I
wish I could have been a better owner to
that dog cuz one of our first dogs too
me and my sister are like damn that was
[__] up yeah we could have taken
better care but then we were kids and my
dad didn't know how to to take care of a
dog he just thought we'd be happy if he
brought home a [__] random ass dog
well my dad sure know he knows how to
take care of dogs now he has so many of
them you I mean [__] jackass they'
replaced you when you're gone there he's
just arguing with it that's not P two
little dogs I bet that's up hey the next
morning I heard my dad talking to the
dog that pissed on my laptop why'd you
do that yeah he's like he's like what's
wrong with you why would you do that you
made me look bad yeah literally he's
doing that he goes why would you do this
he's like
and like the door's closed but you can
see him like lecturing this dog and it's
like dude his [__] dog doesn't know
what's that's your fault he's still
looking to blame somebody else you know
and so he found a
dog oh [__] shout outs to uh Korean
parents well guys that wraps up this
episode of The Genius brain podcast do
your best love your parents yep every
Sundays at 12 pm check out secret
society s CTS o c IE T
y.com your podcast uh Bible study at
Momo yes uh hav't updated since last
February he he'll he'll he'll do it I'll
do it I'll figure it out uh thank you
guys for listening we have a great New
Year we're obviously in this new studio
um still the same [__] same fun [__] is
always going to be great genius sprin
every Sundays at 12:00 p.m. you can
catch us on all audio platforms if
you're not watching this on video like
comment subscribe and share and we'll
see you all next time peace peace